[Música]
la costa noreste de eeuu lamenta la
muerte de al menos 40 personas tras las
inundaciones provocadas por aida los
remanentes de esta tormenta
sorprendieron a nueva york nueva jersey
y pensilvania aun con la posibilidad de
que la cifra de fallecidos siga en
aumento tenemos informe desde la gran
manzana
más de 12 millones de estudiantes
volvieron este jueves a las clases en
francia el gobierno celebra el regreso
de la presencialidad pero hay temores
por su impacto en la situación de la
pandemia hay preocupación por la
presencia de la variante delta
el mundo espera la formación del nuevo
gobierno talibán los islamistas aseguran
que darán este paso en los próximos días
en france 24 tenemos los detalles de
esta noticia desde kabul con nuestro
equipo sobre el terreno
momento de actualizar la información en
france 24 gracias por seguir en nuestra
señal mi nombre es juan pupiales al
menos 40 muertos es el saldo que dejan
los vestigios de la tormenta ied en la
costa noreste de eeuu un nivel inusual
de lluvias torrenciales sorprendió a los
estados de nueva york nueva jersey y
pensilvania las autoridades han
calificado estas precipitaciones como
históricas el propio metro de la gran
manzana se vio sobrepasado por la
irrupción del agua precisamente son
estas inundaciones las principales
causantes de los decesos y con la
ampliación de estos detalles está
nuestra corresponsal en nueva york' mam
en sala
si de esas víctimas mortales 13 hay que
lamentar las aquí en nueva york entre
ellas una niña de tan sólo dos años y
desgraciadamente esa cifra total podría
seguir aumentando a medida que avanzan
las labores de rescate porque todavía
hay mucha gente atrapada en vehículos y
en casas hay hogares que se han
convertido en auténticas trampas
mortales porque el agua entraba en ellas
y era más peligroso quedarte quedarse
dentro que salir los servicios de
emergencia trabajan todavía a estas
horas a contrarreloj en una tarea que no
es nada fácil porque hay todavía cientos
de carreteras cortadas solamente en
pensilvania más de 380 muchas de ellas
vías principales se han convertido en
auténticos ríos y para circular por
ellas hay que hacerlo con barcas esto
está dificultando las labores de
socorrer a las personas que se han
quedado atrapadas hay más de 150 mil
clientes sin suministro eléctrico y las
empresas ya han dicho que tardarán en
restablecer la energía porque los
destrozos son muchos y muy cuantiosos no
se veía una tormenta así desde hacía
muchos años en todo este área
tri-estatal
nueva york pensilvania y nueva yersey la
gobernadora de nueva york la recién
estrenada gobernadora de nueva york hoy
decía que se trata de un inundaciones
históricas y que hablar de algo sin
precedentes es quedarse corto ha pedido
ayuda al presidente yo baida en que hoy
mismo en una declaración ante la nación
ha dicho que aportará todo el apoyo
federal que sea necesario y ha dicho que
ahora mismo se están centrando en cuatro
áreas una restablecer el suministro
eléctrico a restablecer el suministro de
gasolina también que en sitios como
luisiana empiezan ya a escasear a ayudar
y apoyar económicamente a las personas
afectadas a los pequeños negocios y dar
cobijo para esta noche y para las
siguientes a todas aquellas personas que
lo necesiten si algo en algo han
coincidido todos los gobiernos
nacionales y locales que hemos podido
escucharlo a lo largo del día de hoy es
que el cambio climático está detrás de
estos terribles hechos y que es algo
cada vez más amenazante y más común
hiram en sala desde nueva york nos
quedamos en eeuu en donde varias voces
de rechazo frente a la ley del estado de
texas que prohíbe el aborto más allá de
las seis semanas de gestación
el propio presidente yo bailé en quien
afirmó que esta normativa desata un caos
constitucional las reacciones en el
siguiente informe
yo bailé en relación a la decisión de
los jueces del tribunal supremo con una
biblioteca declaración para el
presidente la decisión de dejar que
tejas promulgó una ley de aborto muy
restrictiva
es un ataque sin precedentes a los
derechos constitucionales de las mujeres
esta decisión crea un caos
inconstitucional e insulta al estado de
derecho
el mandatario demócrata asegura que su
administración actuara rápidamente para
garantizar que las mujeres de texas
tengan un acceso seguro y legal al
aborto en el estado conservador muchas
mujeres han tenido durante mucho tiempo
este endurecimiento de la ley tenemos
una pandemia que hace estragos fallos en
la red una tormenta que mató a gente
hemos tenido todos estos problemas aquí
en texas y sin embargo están ocupados
prohibiendo el aborto a partir del
miércoles posiblemente las mujeres de
texas ya no podrán abortar después de
las 6 semanas de embarazo salvo en casos
de peligro para la salud de la mujer
ahora más del 85% de los abortos se
realizan después de ese momento según la
planificación familiar aún más polémico
es el hecho de que el texto deja la
ejecución de la ley en manos de los
ciudadanos
hasta 10.000 dólares por denunciar
cualquier recurso al aborto tardío así
como a los médicos que lo realizan
tenemos derecho a demandar a las mujeres
y a las personas que las puedan ayudar a
abortar esto es completamente absurdo
el derecho al aborto en eeuu está
garantizado desde 1973 tras el famoso
caso de robo contra white pero ahora
mismo parece claramente amenazado por
algunos funcionarios electos
republicanos que están decididos a
endurecer la legislación en un momento
en el que el tribunal supremo de eeuu
está compuesto mayoritariamente por
jueces conservadores
en francia- más de 12 millones de
estudiantes y cerca de 900 1200
volvieron este jueves a los colegios
algo que el gobierno califica como una
victoria y esto que pese a que cerca de
la mitad de la población entre 12 y 17
años cuenta ya con el esquema completo
de vacunas hay preocupación por el
riesgo que este regreso de la
presencialidad escolar pueda tener en el
país galo en medio de la variante del
está ese es el informe
con desinfectante en la puerta así son
recibidos los alumnos esa es la nueva
normalidad en el regreso a clases de los
niños franceses en marsella una clase
tuvo bienvenida presidencia que quiere
ser cuando seas grande un presidente
quiero ser presidente o vendedor de
automóviles para una nueva compañía
bueno esas dos cosas no tienen nada en
común me gustan los carros sí pero los
doctores están preocupados la tasa de
infección entre los niños es superior a
la del año pasado por estas fechas y
alrededor del 37% de los adolescentes en
francia todavía no están vacunados la
pandemia va a empeorar otra vez en
francia siempre que nos sigamos
reuniendo todavía hay 9 millones 400.000
niños menores de 12 años que no están
vacunados y 9.300.000 adultos o personas
mayores de los 12 años que no están
vacunadas todos los niños mayores de 6
años tienen que usar una máscara adentro
si un estudiante de primaria o
bachillerato entra en contacto con un
caso de kobe los miembros de su clase
que están vacunados no tendrán que
aislarse pero para los estudiantes más
jóvenes la clase entera tendrá que tener
un tiempo fuera los maestros están
haciendo su mejor esfuerzo para evitar
contagios
hay más caras disponibles para
estudiantes y visitantes el
antibacterial en todos los salones de
clases y áreas comunes purificadores de
aire sensores de co2 en los salones
protocolos barreras de plástico en el
comedor limitando el contacto de
diferentes grados limitación de masas o
colectivo para ayudar a mantener la baja
propagación del virus el ministro de
educación ha anunciado un plan de seis
mil test de saliva a la semana en los
colegios de toda francia
vamos a organizar en donde este jueves
un grupo de unas 50 mujeres salió a
protestar en irak la tercera ciudad más
grande del país esto con su rostro
descubierto sin burka estas mujeres
defienden su derecho a trabajar y
estudiar también denuncian la nula
participación que tiene en el nuevo
régimen talibán que ya ha reconocido que
será poco probable ver a mujeres en el
nuevo ejecutivo del país
y precisamente el enviado especial de
france 24 en afganistán civil payam nos
cuenta lo que se sabe de la formación de
un nuevo gobierno de los islamistas este
es el informe
que
si nos basamos en los rumores de las
calles de kabul tendremos este nuevo
gobierno dentro de poco esto es lo que
sugiere el alto responsable de ramadí
uno de los portavoces de la línea dura
de la jefatura del talibán la lesión del
psiquismo a mí moro es que sería una
cuestión de horas o de días lo que se
dice también es que la gran jefatura
espiritual del talibán y la acusada que
está recluido en la clandestinidad
décadas desde hace mucho tiempo estaría
en camino a kabul y ya estaría en kabul
cabe mencionar que es un hombre secreto
no existe ni una foto no sabemos cuál es
su aspecto pero materializaría la
formación del primer gobierno del
emirato islámico de afganistán del
talibán que tomó el poder hace unos diez
días eso significa que el talibán debe
actuar con velocidad primero para
ofrecer garantías a la comunidad
internacional
el país está al borde de la la situación
social la situación humanitaria no hay
más efectivo en la calle los bancos
están cerrados las administraciones no
funcionan también se trata de ofrecer
garantías a la población y la población
no es la misma que cuando el talibán
estaba en el poder en 1996 está mucho
más educada se emancipó durante 20 años
y es cierto que el talibán tuvo que
actuar con velocidad de ofrecer
garantías a la población entonces
podemos esperar un gobierno mañana o el
sábado
el equipo de france 24 presente en
afganistán en noticias de la región del
presidente de méxico andrés manuel lópez
obrador anunció hoy que le pedirá al
presidente de eeuu job aiden que tiene
las causas de la inmigración forzada y
ofrezca visas temporales de trabajo para
las personas de centroamérica y de
mexico las declaraciones llegan mientras
una nueva caravana de migrantes
centroamericanos y haitianos avanza
hacia el norte hoy en el estado de
chiapas al sur del país decenas de
personas fueron detenidas el presidente
mexicano aseguró que hará la petición a
través de una
la semana próxima más tarde
le envío una carta
porque no podemos
sólo estar
deteniendo reteniendo
hay que atender las causas
la gente no sale
por gusto
y este viernes comienza en ciudad de
mexico la segunda ronda de
conversaciones entre el gobierno de
venezuela y la oposición esos diálogos
se retoman dos días después de que la
plataforma que aglutina a los partidos
detractores del oficialismo anunciara su
participación en las elecciones
regionales de noviembre después de tres
años de boicot cabe recordar que esta es
una mesa que avanza sin la presencia de
maduro ni del opositor juan guaidó que
en su lugar enviaron a sus respectivos
representantes
vamos a bolivia porque el departamento
de santa cruz uno de los motores
económicos del país vive el azote de
unos fuertes incendios que afectan a
seis municipios
hablamos de 840 mil hectáreas quemadas
en las 146 emergencias que se registran
en la región hasta el momento no se ha
podido cuantificar el daño de flora y
fauna
a continuación noticias de la pandemia
de 19 a la tina cuba el único país de la
región que desarrolla vacunas contra el
kobe 19 anunció que presentará a sus
tres candidatas ante la organización
mundial de la salud el gobierno de la
isla ya autorizó el uso de emergencia de
sus tres potenciales vacunas y según
funcionarios cubanos esperan ahora
comenzar intercambios con la o ms para
obtener el visto bueno definitivo
en brasil de hacer marcha la aplicación
de la tercera dosis de la vacuna contra
el 19 para adultos mayores ciudades como
salvador y são luís ya realizan este
proceso desde el lunes y desde el
miércoles la dosis de refuerzo se aplica
ya también en río de janeiro
el doctor anthony fauci principal
epidemiólogo de la casa blanca afirmó
que es muy probable que los
estadounidenses necesiten una tercera
dosis de la vacuna contra el jove 19
para que se considere que tienen el
esquema completo de acuerdo con pau sin
la decisión final la tomarán los
reguladores de la administración de
medicamentos y alimentos la rda
sólo 1 de cada 4 países en el mundo
cuenta con políticas para apoyar a los
pacientes que sufren de demencia ya los
familiares de estos según la ms más de
55 millones viven con esta enfermedad
neurológica una cifra que en 2030 podría
alcanzar los 78 millones cada año la
demencia le cuesta al mundo más de un
billón 300 mil dólares en 2015 los
ministros de salud de varios países
acordaron un plan global global contra
la demencia que incluye el diagnóstico
temprano y brindar ayudas pero los
objetivos previstos a 10 años no se
están cumpliendo
terminamos con música porque la banda
sueca abba anunció su primer álbum en
cuatro décadas esta agrupación una de
las más influyentes en la historia del
pop publicará su trabajo guayas el
próximo 5 de noviembre y ofrecerá una
serie de conciertos virtuales nos
despedimos con algunos de sus clásicos
[Música]
bueno
cierre musical gracias por estar con
nosotros la información continúen
france24 france24 puntocom
[Música]